in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Jason
and Brittany are with us hey guys how
are you good how are you better than I
deserve welcome were y'all from
Kannapolis North Carolina fun very cool
did you drive over that's not a bad
Drive yeah we drove yeah that's right
it's not a short drive though it's a
couple of long states it was like six
hours or something yes yeah okay very
cool welcome and here to do your
debt-free scream yes sir
and how much have you paid off I paid
off about seven hundred ten thousand oh
okay
no small potatoes there how long did
this take it's about four years seven
months okay and making what kind of
money during those years for the past
seven or eight years I probably made a
couple hundred thousand a year but for
the past couple years I was able to to
crack this seven-figure income up over a
million yes sir
Wow impressive what do you do I do
medical equipment Sales and Leasing Wow
you're killing it congratulations thank
you so 710,000 there's got to be a
different story with this it's not like
credit card debt here I'm guessing so
know what happened and tell me about the
whole four year process and what kind of
debt was this it was all just mostly
mortgage I had a large mortgage had a
second mortgage a couple cars I didn't
have any credit card debt and just went
to the financial peace thing at church
and started listening to it when I would
when I would go running in the evenings
with like an iPod yeah iPod and I just
decided to shift my way of thinking cool
so Brittany where were you in this
process tell me how this worked he just
came to me and told me that he wanted to
pay the house off and so I was
definitely on board with that and ready
to help very cool so what's this home
worth it's probably worth a million good
no way to go man you're killing it they
crowd are you guys an excellent job so
over four point seven years you've went
ahead and worked the baby steps and
you're working baby step six at that
point and just throwing extra you could
find at the house and extra at the house
while you're doing your I'm sure your
15% into retirement right yes it okay
very cool
and that's impressive how's it feel you
don't have
I'll spray with no sir I lived it was
different for me because I was I never
was one like some of your callers that
was struggling as much but I was one
that was just making a bunch of payments
you know if I can make the payment I
thought I could afford it mm-hmm and
then I decided that uh I had a lot more
money if I would just get rid of the
debt and you know you had you could pay
cash for stuff
absolutely absolutely very cool so I at
the break I met the moms both moms are
with you right isn't your mom and her
mom yes okay so what were they saying
while you guys were doing all of this
they didn't really say a whole lot my
mind their own business do they yeah my
mom did have a very small mortgage debt
when I was you know on a roll with all
this that we were able to knock out as
well so we were you know we made her
part of the plan oh that's cool yeah
very neat that's a nice touch yeah well
that's that's what you can do when
you're killing it and that's great it's
very well done thank you well it's good
to have some cheerleaders I know they
came along with you and your kids or how
old are your kids and what our ages and
names they're ten and five my daughter's
name's Jay Lee and my son is Jackson
okay well you you've got an unusually
large shovel with your income but you
also have paid off an unusual amount of
debt during that time so just knock off
a zero and you got you know regular
folks stuff that they're dealing with
but it's still the same process so
Brittany what do you tell people the key
to becoming debt-free is if they heard
you became debt-free um just make sure
you stay on track and watch what you
spend okay did you cut is there anything
in particular you cut back not
particularly I mean we just made sure we
didn't have any credit card debt from
one paid cash just paying cash for
whatever you do and that keeps the rest
of it freed up to attack it with okay
cool what do you tell folks Jason hey
you just got to make up your mind it's
like going on diet you know once you
wake up and decide you're gonna do it
you know nothing to it you know very
cool well congratulations you two
think he's very proud of you very proud
for you your great American success
story very well done
interesting interesting situation
right jaylee and Jackson right yes sir
are they gonna join you alright very
cool cuz their whole lives have been
changed now this is amazing
pretty kids alright Jason and Britney
from Charlotte North Carolina area
710,000 paid off in 4.7 years
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one absolutely very
well done you guys man that's amazing
great job hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you are not a victim
you're not a victim of big corporations
you're not a victim of Wall Street
you're not a victim of capitalism you're
not a victim of wealth inequality you're
not a victim of racism you're not a
victim
you